this video is brought to you by
Squarespace from websites to online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business head squarespace.com
for a free trial and when you're ready
for launch go to Squarespace calm /by
graphics to save 10% of your first
purchase of a website or domain
[Music]
Alexander the Great's stood at the head
of the world's most feared army using it
to carve for himself an absolutely vast
empire he crushed the Persian Empire and
then thrust his way into Egypt and India
to become the acknowledged king of kings
then at the height of his power he was
cut down leaving behind a legacy of
heroism divinity and a tyranny in
today's by graphics we examined the
incredible life of Alexander
[Music]
the future Alexander the Great was born
in Pella Macedonia the capital of
ancient Greece because the Greeks used a
different calendar than we do we can't
actually say for certainty when exactly
he was born most historians believe that
he was born on July the 20th 356 BCE he
was the son of the king of Macedon
Philip the seconds and the principal one
of his seven wives Olympius of Epirus as
the son of the king Alexander he was
raised by a nurse
he had private tutors with the first one
being a relative by the name of Leonidas
this man was a strict teacher who
demanded a high level of academic rigor
of the young prince Leonid a schooled
Alexander in such subjects as maths
reading in languages at around the age
of 7 Alexander started instruction under
one of his father's generals a man by
the name of the Lysimachus of arcanine
eeeh his job was to teach the boy to
behave like a noble Alexander was taught
to play the lyre as well as to write and
to hunt bison Marcus also gave him
instruction in fighting when he was 10
years old Alexander's father was
presented with a horse for sale by a
trader but the horse
it was wild and no one could mount it
Philip was about to dismiss this trader
when young Alexander stepped forward and
said that he was able to tame the animal
the boy set himself to breaking the
animal and becoming its master this was
a dangerous task even for a grown man
but young Alexander showed impressive
determination and perseverance to
conquer this horse his father the king
was so proud of his son that even gave
way to tears he told his son my boy you
must find a kingdom big enough for your
ambitions Macedon is too small for you
after saying this he purchased the horse
for him he named the horse Bucephalus
which means ox head he rode the horse
over most of his career and he carried
it with him into many battles when mr.
fellows died of old age 30 Alexander he
named a city after him when he was 13
Alexander's education it was taken to a
new level when Philip employed the
greatest philosopher of the day
aristotle to tutor his son the daily
lessons were held at the temple of
nymphs at me a sir alexander lived there
with other royal children in a sort of
very privileged version of a morning
school some of the teenagers that
Alexander associated with at that time
would later become his generals
Aristotle provides an instruction in
religion morals philosophy art and logic
in appreciation for the education that
he was providing for his son the king
rebuilt Aristotle's home in the town of
steggy wrap this previously been
destroyed by the same king he also
purchased every slave in the town and
freed them when he reached the age of 16
Alexander was handed a huge
responsibility his father had just
declared war on Byzantium and he was
about to lead his army into battle he
left the capital city of Macedon under
the control of Alexander it was a huge
display of trust on behalf of the king
that other soon took advantage a group
of European tribes known as the Thracian
mady rose up in rebellion under the
impression that the kingdom was weakened
under the teenage Prince but Alexander
he was up to the challenge he sent his
army in and the Thracians were quickly
driven out of their territory
he had the area repopulated with greeks
and renamed it Alexandra Palace when
King Philip returned from battle he was
extremely impressed with the way that
his son had dealt with the Thracian
revolt he gave Alexander his own small
army and the drop of stomping out any
minor revolves that crops up throughout
the empire over the next three years
Alexander joined his father on a number
of military campaigns to dominate the
Greek States on one occasion it was
claimed that Alexander saved his
father's life during a campaign against
the Greek state of paranthas they
defeated the cities of olay Tia and
Anfisa then they came up against the
united armies of Athens and Thebes they
always met during an epic battle near
Kara near Envy OSHA Philip took the
right wing of the army and put the left
wing under Alexander with Macedonia's
top generals having to answer to him for
Thebes and Athenians were defeated
giving Philip control of the majority of
the Greek states he then said about
uniting them into a Hellenic alliance
having stamped his dominance on a
largely united Greece Philip set his
sights on conquering Persia this time he
left his son in control of a hugely
expanded empire when he returns philip
added an extra wife to his household
her name was Cleopatra Eurydice this
marriage but Alexander's position as
heir to the throne in danger Cleopatra
was a full Macedonian while Alexander
was only half Macedonian this meant that
if Cleopatra had a son this one would
supersede Alexandra in the line of
succession during the wedding feast
Attalus the uncle of Cleopatra who was
one of Philips top generals was heard to
drunkenly request of the gods that the
king and his new bride should quickly
produce a son Alexander heard the plea
and he was not happy he went up to the
general and threw a cup at his head and
said you villain what am I then a
bastard
Alexander felt abandoned by his father
after the wedding he and his mother left
Macedon and headed for Paris where a
mother's brother King Alexander the
first resided leaving his mother there
he continued on sir Illyria in the
western part of the Balkan Peninsula he
was welcomed as a visiting dignitary by
the illyrian King back in Macedon the
king was saddened by his son's departure
he sent a messenger to persuade Alex to
return the reality was that Philip had
never intended to displace Alexander as
heir however shortly after Alexander's
return to Macedon there was more tension
between the two Phillip arranged for
Alexander's younger brother Ross accord
Philip to marry Alexander's trouble
making friends persuaded him that the
king was again trying to cut him off
from inheriting the throne
however when for the part of the rumours
he angrily banished the troublemakers in
October of 336 BC the Macedonian raw
court was in eggie for the wedding of
Alexander the first of Epirus and
Alexander's sister Cleopatra of Macedon
Philip was assassinated by one of his
bodyguards as he entered into the town's
theatres the reasons for the
assassination are unclear but the
results was very clear twenty-year-old
Alexander was now king of Macedonia
Alexander was shaken by his father's
murder
he knew that the plotters were intent on
stealing the throne out from under him
if he didn't take decisive action he too
would see be debt he began by having his
cousin M enters the fourth put to death
along with a pair of Macedonian princes
from lie senators he also ordered the
execution of Attalus the uncle of his
stepmother Cleopatra his mother
saw danger in the form of Cleopatra the
women who had married Philip a few years
earlier
she arranged for Cleopatra runs the
daughter she'd had with Philip to be
killed she also poisoned others leaving
some of them mentally and physically
disabled for life Alexander was furious
at his mother poisoning his half-sister
who he didn't consider to be a threat to
him when the news that the stable
dominant rule of Philip had been
replaced by his 20 year old son a number
of states were emboldened to rise up in
revolt recently conquered states
including Athens and Thessaloniki
attempted to reassert their independence
despite his advisers urging a diplomatic
response Alexander was determined to
stamp his dominance on the rebellious
States he personally led a force of
3,000 soldiers to sort things out in
many cases the uncooperative state's
resistance evaporated at the sight of
Alexandra at the head of his army those
who didn't were put down very swiftly he
rode through the various states that his
father had United Alexander he was
heaped with praise his swift action had
cemented his power and provided a
seamless transition from his father's
rule to his having put down a series of
revolts Alexander wanted to ensure that
there were no further uprisings in his
second year as king he took his army
east and defeated the Thracian people
who had rebelled against him four years
ago he also conquered the tribally tribe
by now Alexander's Macedonian Kingdom it
had become so large that if he went
north to put down a rebellion people in
the South would rise up then when he
went south those in the north would
rebel again what was needed was a show
of dominance that would prevent further
uprisings with the northern states
brought under control Alexander took his
army south he went directly to Thebes
the only southern state which had dared
to rebel Alexander he was keen to make
an example of them the city was
completely destroyed he then created a
series of smaller cities that were
populated with people from other areas
this assault it had finally brought all
of Greece under Alexander's Dominion he
now set out to conquer Asia to keep the
home kingdom under control he but a
general by the name of Antipater in
charge with a sizeable army
in 334 BCE Alexander marched a forty
thousand strong army out of Macedonia he
was focused on taking possession of the
entire Persian Empire which he
considered to be a personal gift to him
from the gods
unlike his father Alexander was never
really interested in achieving
diplomatic negotiations he was all about
taking what he wanted by a force of arms
the first resistance that the Macedonian
army found as they swept into Persia was
that the Battle of Granicus River this
river was a formidable obstacle that the
Greek army would have to cross the
Persians under the memnon of Rhodes
positioned themselves around the river
in order to await the arrival of the
enemy their strength was a little over
half of that of the Greeks Alexander led
his army into a direct frontal attack
using a classic wedge-shaped assault
they drove into the middle of the
Persian line in the melee that followed
it was reported that Alexander
personally killed several Persians he
was almost felled with an axe blow but
he was able to recover and save himself
the superior numbers of the Greeks
combined with their use of the Lance to
counter the javelin attacks of the
Persians eventually won the day the
Persians they were defeated and chased
from the field total Persian casualties
were around 4,000 with Alexander's army
having lost a tenth of that number there
had been about 18,000 Greek mercenaries
who had fought for the Persians in this
battle they were captured by the Greek
army Alexander considered these men to
be traitors to their country and
deserving of no mercy yet half of them
executed and the rest taken as slaves
following this victory Alexander took
possession of Sardis the provincial
capital of the kingdom of Lydia
he then traveled down the Ionian coast
most towns welcomed him as a conqueror
and he duly declared that they were free
of their Persian overlords and able to
rule themselves as autonomous states as
he moved down the coast the Persian Navy
was constantly trying to engage
Alexander in battle however he resisted
preferring to fight on the land new
things south Alexander came to
Halicarnassus where he engaged in his
first full-scale siege operation the
Persian fleet had sails to the port of
Halicarnassus where it set up a base
prior to Alexander's arrival the Queen
of Halicarnassus a Durov carrier had
been driven from the city and replaced
by a satrap named or on to beatty's Aida
had set herself up in the fortress of
Olinda
when Alexander rode in she surrendered
the fort to him the defenders of the
city of Halleck own ass
now set up to defend the city still
Alexander's army it managed to break
through the city walls how that they
were driven back by the catapults from
within the city a renewed asalto became
this peril and stormed through a second
time memnon of Rhodes who was in defense
of the city having evaded capture at
Granicus River set the city on fire
before retreating the Persian fleet they
also withdrew Alexander formally
returned the city to Queen ADA in return
she adopted him as a son therefore
making sure that the city would pass to
him on her death so look you might not
be out there at conquering the worlds
but if you want to conquer the internet
for yourself your brand's and your
business why should do with Squarespace
see what I did there
pretty good transition right Squarespace
and empowers dreamers makers and doers
like Alexander the Great
if he was around today he'd be using a
Squarespace it gives people the tools to
bring their creative ideas to life
Squarespace makes it easy - they have an
all-in-one platform so you can claim a
domain build a website and even sell
online there's no fussing around getting
a domain from one place and bringing it
over to another then working out how to
sell something or whatever it's all just
done neat and tidally on Squarespace
that's pretty nice plus it's not gonna
look too shabby either
and though not too shabby I mean it's
gonna look pretty fantastic they've got
award-winning templates which is a
perfect starting point then you then
just customize those templates until
your heart's content and it looks just
how you want it they've also got 24/7
customer support by chat or email and
also got loads of accessible and not
confusing documentation on how to make a
great website Plus email marketing so
you can keep in touch with your fans or
your customers look Squarespace
it makes it easy so get that domain get
that slide built get up a shop if you
want to and you're good to go
just head to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to go launch
go to Squarespace calm /bi graphics and
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain let's get back to
Alexander and his conquering of the
world
control of Halicarnassus and the coastal
cities meant that the Persians could no
longer dock theft fleet continuing on
his conquest
Alexander arrived at the Phrygian
capital of gordium they was here
according to Greek legend that he was
taken before a famed ox cart which was
tied with an incredibly complicated rope
not known as the Gordian knot it was
said that whoever could undo the knot
would become ruler of Asia Alexander is
said to have examined the knot closely
than having no idea how to undo it he
pulled out his sword and cut the rib in
half with a single stroke we don't know
whether the story is true but you know
it makes very good tale continuing south
Alexander's army encountered for the
first time a more formidable army than
his own it was under the leadership of
Darius the third king of the our
community Empire of Persia despite being
outnumbered Alexander's tactical skill
and his personal bravery and leading
from the front they won the day Darius
who was completely overwhelmed by this
loss he took to his heels before leaving
his army a great treasure and all this
kingdom
Alexander claimed at all
with the absolute dominance of
Alexander's Greek army over the Persians
bordering nations began to panic the
all-conquering warrior king had
developed an aura of invincibility and
many nations simply acceded to him as he
entered their territory by 332 he had
taken Syria and the coastal advance he
then set about taking tyre which was a
coastal island base sitting about a mile
out in the Mediterranean Sea conquering
the island would be a great challenge to
Alexander with the combination of the
sea and higher walls that surrounded the
islands leaving him with very few
options for seven months Alexander
blockaded the islands preventing either
entry or exit he then had his army built
a causeway out of rocks in order to
allow them to get to the city walls when
the city walls were eventually breached
Alexander was so angry with the extended
Tyrian holed out of it according to
contemporary historian Arian of Nike
media he ordered the massacre of up to
eight thousand citizens following the
taking of Tyre most of the cities on
Alexander's campaign route surrendered
without putting up any resistance the
only one city that stood firm as he
wound his way to Egypt was Gaza as the
city sent it off a hill it looked as if
Alexander was in for another protracted
siege yet this was one siege that sort
of looked like an impossibility the
walls were according to Alexander's
engineers too high and too thick to be
penetrated for Alexander though this was
just the source of challenge that got
his juices flowing he became even more
determined to conquer the city he was
convinced that destiny was gonna find a
way for him the Greek army made three
desperate attempts to breach the walls
eventually on the final day they made
that breakthrough but the cost it was
terrific with thousands of men falling
to the missiles of the enemy Alexander
himself suffered a serious shoulder
wound once the city was taken severe
punishment was exact upon the
inhabitants with the men being
slaughtered in the women and children
being sold into slavery when the
all-conquering Greek army approached the
holy Jewish City of Jerusalem the Jews
through open the gates and welcomed him
into their midst it was reported that
Alexander was taken into the Great
Temple of Solomon and shown a prophetic
text from the Book of Daniel that
referred to him as a mighty king who
would conquer the land
Alexander left Jerusalem in peace and
headed south to lay claim to Egypt in
that land he was welcomed as a liberator
the people proclaimed him to be a son of
the gods and gave him reverence on the
same level as though in fair
he founded the city of Alexandria which
would become the major trading center in
future times
[Music]
leaving Egypt Alexander traveled back
north as he set his sights on take in
Babylon this is the Persian capital
where King Darius had positioned himself
Alexander marched with forty seven
thousand men but Darius had amassed a
massive army which some historians have
put at 1 million men the two armies met
near the village of gregor mela at the
forefront of his lines Darius placed
chariots armed with scythes and 15
elephants in an attempt to mow through
the Greek lines in response Alexander
placed his light troops up front to
negate the effects of the chariots with
missiles directed at their horses those
chariots that made it to the Greek line
were allowed to pass harmlessly through
where they were surrounded and captured
Darius himself was in a size armed
chariot but when his charioteer was
felled by a javelin he jumped from the
chariot mounted a horse and fled seeing
this many of his own men they followed
suit panic ensued and the battle was
over
following the conquest of Babylon
Alexander moved on to Susur and then to
the Persian city of Persepolis he then
determines to hunt down and kill Darius
the disgraced Persian king in order to
prevent any further reprisals he finally
found Darius but he'd already been
killed one of his most trusted men
Bursar's had killed him and now claimed
the throne for himself
Alexander now set his sights on tracking
down Bessus who had fled into Central
Asia
Alexander explored much of Asia he
founds a number of cities naming each of
them in his own honor
eventually Bessus was betrayed by his
own men and handed over for execution on
his return to Persia Alexander he was
hailed as the King of Kings he began to
adopt Persian habits including dressing
in Persian clothing and following
Persian customs this was troubling to
many Greeks including some of his
generals by now Alexander had been away
from Macedon for many years he had left
and tippet ur is the military ruler of
the city and he had effectively
maintained the peace however Alexander
was obstinately requesting troop
reinforcements which made the defenses
of the city weaker
[Music]
Alexander now set his sights on
conquering the Indian subcontinent he
sent delegates ahead of him to demand
that the Indian leaders submit to him
some of the clans acquiesced but others
didn't these plans would be furiously
attacked by Alexander's army complete
villages they were burned to the grounds
and people were killed with impunity
the Greek army met their strongest
resistance at the hands of King Porus in
the punjab region the Indian forces were
defeated in battle but Alexander was so
impressed with the tactics and bravery
of pooris that he offered a co rulership
to him while Alexander would control the
lands he would hand the day-to-day
running of Punjab to poorest by now
Alexander had conquered more territory
than any other ruler in history but he
was still not satisfied
he wanted to advance even deeper into
the Indian subcontinent however his army
they didn't they simply had enough
the soldiers revolted refusing to
advance any further the generals sided
with them and one of them general CONUS
told Alexander that the men longed to
again see their parents their wives
their children their homeland
Alexander sympathized and decided that
it was time to go home but he continued
to conquer villages and claim more lands
on his return route in order to placate
his men he sent older and disabled
soldiers directly back to Macedonia but
this act it backfired the men thought
that they were all going directly home
when Alexander marched then on further
conquests there was a lot of anger the
men of his army they began to openly
criticize Alexander they were especially
unhappy with his adoption of Persian
customs and the appointing of Persian
officers to command them in an attempt
to win favor Alexander ensured the
Macedonian troops were ruled over by
Macedonian officers he also held a huge
banquet for his men to celebrate the
years of victory after returning to
Persia Alexander established himself in
the great Palace of Nebuchadnezzar he
plans further campaigns of conquest into
Arabia but these would never come to
pass
[Music]
Alexander died suddenly on June the 10th
or the 11th 332 BCE the cause of death
is unclear with there being two main
theories and both of these theories
involve the excessive use of alcohol in
one accounts he develops a fever after a
24-hour drinking binge and the other he
became sick after drinking a bowl of
unmixed wine of course this also been
talk of poisoning the death of the King
of Kings at the height of his power was
a huge shot to the entire world people
could not believe that such a strong
dynamic and heroic individual could be
struck down without warning Alexander's
body was placed in a gold sarcophagus
after much disputing he was laid to rest
in Alexandria over the next centuries
many famous leaders came to pay respects
but his body it was not left in peace it
is said that the Roman Emperor Augustus
accidentally damaged the corpse and
Caligula stole Alexander's breastplate
such incidents prompted Emperor
septimius severus to close the tomb to
the public in 200 CE II where it was
taken is unknown today the location of
Alexander's tomb is one of history's
great mysteries so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below also
please do check out our sponsor
Squarespace like I said that what
Alexander the Great would have used
you'll find a link to them below and as
always thank you for watching